[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
venir c'est paris saclay est classé dans
les 20 premières depuis 2020 donc depuis
la première apparition de l'université
paris-x sacré dans ce classement
pourquoi est ce qu'elle est apparue
directement dans les 20 premières parce
que c'était le moment où on a commencé à
considérer la façon dont fonctionne
réellement l'université paris saclay
c'est à dire
l'université en elle-même issue de
l'université paris-sud les
établissements composantes qui constitue
l université paris saclay et les
organismes de recherche et les
universités qui sont associés à
l'université paris-x sacré
antérieurement tout cela a été vu de
l'extérieur notamment au niveau
international de manière segmenté
fractionné dissocier maintenant on
regarde cet ensemble là comme un tout et
ça n'a rien d'artificiel puisque ça fait
très longtemps que l'ensemble de ses
institutions travaillent ensemble y
compris avec les organismes de recherche
qui pèse la moitié en gros de la
recherche fret à l'université paris
saclay et du coup on a fait un bond dans
le classement de shanghai entre la façon
dont étaient classés individuellement
notamment l'université paris sud et
maintenant la façon dont est classé
l'université paris saclay est évidemment
d'universités paris saclay qui
représente dans une certaine mesure une
partie de la recherche et de la
formation française est très heureuse
d'être classé dans ses 20 premiers
le classement de shanghai s'est quand
même d'abord un classement recherche et
c'est vrai qu'il a probablement plus
d'impact pour les diplômes recherche
pour les chercheurs en général donc
niveau master doctorat
on a entre 40 et 45% de doctorants qui
sont étrangers la première aire
géographique dont ils viennent c'est
l'asie c'est d'un endroit aussi où on a
un impact plus fort je dirais ou un
regard plus attentif à ces classements
là donc c'est un impact j'irai sur
l'attractivité vis-à-vis de ces
étudiants-là qui viennent soit pour
venir au master soit en doctorat ensuite
dire est que au delà d'avoir des
retombées en termes de satisfaction ça
fait toujours plaisir d'avoir une belle
reconnaissance je pense que c'est
surtout des retombées en termes de
visibilité et d'attractivité en fait il
ya vraiment un enjeu c'est être dans les
20 à 25 noms que les gens arrivent à
retenir et quand on arrive dans le top
25 le top 20 ça permet en fait d'être
très visible à l'international
[Musique]